If you don't mind, come to the festival again at the Christmas party
at home. You've been a younger sister as a family member
.
Yeah, when the festival comes, moms will be happy.
In addition, the story of a special product
Eh,
if you open the special product mouth, it's just
like a fool
Festival
Yuzu-chan's favorite Meisa I'm meeting a stranger in front of Nara station
I wonder if I'm enjoying Christmas nowadays
What are you saying?  Don't ask, it's
not a lie,
Imaaki-san has a smartphone for a part-time job.
If you try this, you might be connected.
Mei-san isn't a serious honor student like Yuzu-chan thinks. The
turret is a very [ __ ].  A terrible person who is willing to lie to Yuzu-chan
Hara I just gave up on that person and
just looked at me
[Music]
Ne
Yuzucha
[Music]
I need you for that child too.
Who was watching the festival the most? It's fishing.
I came here today
. It's the life of telling me to care about the festival.
It seems like I left a new before the
festival. No matter how you think about it, it's a defeat of the specialty. Yeah, the
Kurapo human meter can
beat the U.
[music]